400 parts per million that's the
approximate concentration of co2 in the
air today what does this even mean for
every 400 molecules of carbon dioxide we
have another million molecules of oxygen
and nitrogen in this room today there
are about 1800 of us imagine just one of
us was wearing a green shirt and you're
asked to find that single person that's
the challenge we're facing when
capturing co2 directly out of the air
sounds pretty easy
pulling co2 out of the air it's actually
really difficult but I'll tell you what
is easy avoiding co2 emissions to begin
with but we're not doing that so now
what we have to think about is going
back pulling co2 back out of the air
even though it's difficult it's actually
possible to do this and I'm going to
share with you today where this
technology of that and where it just may
be heading in the near future now the
earth naturally removes co2 from the air
by seawater soils plants and even rocks
and although engineers and scientists
are doing the invaluable work to
accelerate these natural processes
simply won't be enough the good news is
we have more thanks to human ingenuity
we have the technology today to remove
co2 out of the air using a chemically
manufactured approach I like to think of
this as a synthetic forest and there are
two basic approaches to growing or
building such a forest one is using co2
grabbing chemicals dissolved in water
another is using solid materials with
co2 grabbing chemicals no matter which
approach you choose they basically look
the same so what I'm showing you here is
what a system might look like to do just
this this is called an air contactor
you can see it has to be really really
wide in order to have a high enough
surface area to process all of the air
required because remember we're trying
to capture just 400 molecules out of a
million using the liquid based approach
to do this you take this high surface
area packing material you fill the
contactor with the packing material use
pumps to distribute liquid across the
packing material and you can use fans as
you can see in the front it's a bubble
the air through the liquid and the co2
in the air is separated from the liquid
by reacting with the really strong
binding co2 molecules in solution and in
order to capture a lot of co2 you have
to make this contact or deeper but
there's an optimization because the
deeper you make that contact are the
more energy you're spending on bubbling
all that air through so air contact is
for direct air kaptur have this unique
characteristic design where they have
this huge surface area but a relatively
thin thickness and now once you've
captured the co2 you have to be able to
recycle that material that you use to
capture it over and over again the scale
of carbon capture is so enormous that
the capture process must be sustainable
and you can't use a material just once
and so recycling the material requires
an enormous amount of heat because think
about it co2 is so diluted in the air
that material is binding it really
strong and so you need a lot of heat in
order to recycle the material and to
recycle the material with that heat what
happens is that concentrated co2 that
you got from dilute co2 in the air is
now released and you produce high purity
co2 and that's really important because
high purity co2 is easier to liquefy
easier to transport whether it's in a
pipeline or a truck or even easier to
use directly say as a fuel or a chemical
so I want to talk a little bit more
about that energy the heat required to
regenerate or recycle these materials
absolutely
dictates the energy and the subsequent
cost of doing this so I ask a question
how much energy do you think that it
takes to remove a million tons of co2
from the air in a given year the answer
is a power plant it takes a power plant
to capture co2 directly from the air
depending on which approach you choose
the power plant could be on the order of
300 to 500 megawatts and you have to be
careful about what kind of power plant
you choose if you choose coal you end up
emitting more co2 than you capture now
let's talk about costs an energy
intensive version of this technology
could cost you as much as a thousand
dollars a ton just to capture it let's
translate that if you were to take that
very expensive co2 and convert it to a
liquid fuel that comes out to $50 a
gallon that's way too expensive it's not
feasible so how can we bring these costs
down that's in part the work that I do
there's a company today a commercial
scale company that can do this as low as
$600 a ton there are several other
companies that are developing
technologies that can do this even
cheaper than that and I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about a few of these
different companies one is called carbon
engineering they're based out of Canada
they use the liquid based approach for
separation combined with burning
superabundant cheap natural gas to
supply the heat required they have a
clever approach that allows them to Co
capture the co2 from the air and the co2
that they generate from burning the
natural gas and so by doing this they
offset excess pollution and they reduce
costs switzerland-based climb works
us-based global thermostat used a
different approach they use solid
materials for capture climb works uses
heat from the earth or geothermal or
even excess steam from other industrial
processes to cut down on pollution and
costs global thermostat takes a
different approach they focus on the
heat required and the speed in which it
moves through the material so that
they're able to release and produce that
co2 at a really fast rate which allows
them to have a more compact design and
overall cheaper costs and there's more
still a synthetic forest has a
significant advantage over a real forest
size this next image that I'm showing
you is a map of the Amazon rainforest
the Amazon is capable of capturing 1.6
billion tons of co2 each year this is
the equivalent of roughly 25% of our
annual emissions in the US the land area
required for a synthetic forest or a
manufacturer direct air capture plant to
capture the same is 500 times smaller in
addition for a synthetic forest you
don't have to build it on arable land so
there's no competition with farmland or
food and there's also no reason to have
to cut down any real trees to do this I
want to step back and I want to bring up
the concept of negative emissions again
negative emissions require that the co2
separated be permanently removed from
the atmosphere forever which means
putting it back underground where it
came from in the first place but let's
face it nobody gets paid to do that
today least not enough so the companies
that are developing these technologies
are actually interested in taking the
co2 and making something useful out of
it a marketable product it could be
liquid fuels plastics or even synthetic
gravel and don't get me wrong these
carbon markets are great but I also
don't want you to be disillusioned these
are not large enough to solve our
climate crisis and so what we need to do
is we need to actually think about what
it could take one thing I'll absolutely
say is positive about the carbon markets
is that the
allow for new capture plants to be built
and with every capture plant bill we
learn more and when we learn more we
have an opportunity to bring costs down
but we also need to be willing to invest
as a global society we could have all of
the clever thinking and technology in
the world but it's not going to be
enough in order for this technology to
have a significant impact on climate we
really need regulation we need subsidies
taxes on carbon there are a few of us
that would absolutely be willing to pay
more but what will be required is that
for carbon neutral carbon negative paths
to be affordable for the majority of
society in order to impact climate in
addition to those kinds of investments
we also need investments in research and
development so what might that look like
in 1966 the u.s. invested about a half a
percent of gross domestic product in the
Apollo program it got people safely to
the moon and back to the earth half a
percent of GDP today it's about a
hundred billion dollars so knowing that
direct air capture is one front and our
fight against climate change imagine
that we could invest twenty percent
twenty billion dollars further let's
imagine that we could get the costs down
to $100 a ton that's going to be hard
but it's part of what makes my job fun
and so what does that look like twenty
billion dollars $100 a ton that requires
us to build 200 synthetic forests each
capable of capturing a million tons of
co2 per year that adds up to about five
percent of u.s. annual emissions it
doesn't sound like much turns out it's
actually significant if you look at the
emissions associated with long-haul
trucking and commercial aircraft they
add up to about five percent our
dependence on liquid fuels makes these
emissions really difficult to avoid
so this investment could absolutely be
significant now what would it take in
terms of land area to do this 200 plants
so it turns out that they would take up
about half the land area of Vancouver
that's if they were fueled by natural
gas but remember the downside of natural
gas it also emits co2 so if you use
natural gas to do direct air capture you
only end up capturing about a third of
what's intended unless you have that
clever approach of CO capture that
carbon engineering does and so if we had
an alternative approach and used wind or
solar to do this the land area would be
about 15 times larger looking at the
state of New Jersey now one of the
things that I think about in my work in
my research is optimizing and figuring
out where we should put these plants and
think about the local resources
available whether it's land water cheap
and clean electricity because for
instance you can use clean electricity
to split water to produce hydrogen which
is an excellent carbon free replacement
for natural gas to supply the heat
required but I want us to reflect a
little bit again on negative emissions
negative missions should not be
considered a silver bullet but they may
help us if we continue to stall it
cutting down on co2 pollution worldwide
but that's also why we have to be
careful this approach is so alluring
that it can even be risky as some may
cling onto it as some kind of total
solution to our climate crisis it may
tempt people to continue to burn fossil
fuels 24 hours a day 365 days a year I
argue that we should not see negative
emissions as a replacement for stopping
pollution but rather as an addition to
an existing portfolio that includes
everything from increased energy
efficiency to low energy carbon to
improved farming
we'll all collectively get us on a path
to net zero emissions one day a little
bit of self reflection my husband is an
emergency physician
and I find myself amazed by the
life-saving work that he and his
colleagues do each and every day yet
when I talked to them about my work on
carbon capture I find that they're
equally amazed and that's because
combating climate change by capturing
carbon isn't just about saving a polar
bear or a glacier it's by saving human
lives
a synthetic forest may not ever be as
pretty as a real one but it could just
enable us to preserve not only the
Amazon but all the people that we love
and cherish as well is all of our future
generations and modern civilization
thank you
[Applause]